do this jump into joe biden and donald
trump hey my man
rock we're going long tonight yeah super
long wow
wait what wait what time is it it's 10
10. really yeah
we've been talking for two hours yeah
man okay we got to stay hydrated
um i i don't like any of the political
establishment i think there's very few
people on either side that i'm that i
like and think are good people
and there's slightly more republicans
than democrats but you know
i think it's because the majority of
both parties are people who like i said
didn't have to do anything
gerrymandering
heavy uh guaranteed districts you end up
with
republican areas that are always gonna
be republican so they're probably gonna
say they don't gotta do anything they'll
be like hey vote for me
or don't ha who cares the democrat says
the same thing
nancy pelosi held up a glass of water
and she said in my district or aocs you
put a d
on this glass of water it's going to get
elected that's a problem
that's a serious problem i disavow nancy
pelosi yeah as you should
uh i like the idea of ranked choice
voting because to me
it would get rid of well actually i'm
not entirely convinced to get rid of
nancy pelosi
term limits would how do you feel about
term limits um i
i haven't seen any evidence that they
lead to a more democratic government i'm
50 50. i could go either way
i though i have to say i really do think
the only reason that nancy pelosi is
still in there right now is because of
fear
democrats are terrified of trump i think
they have good reason to be
but you have somebody shahid bhutar is
running against nancy pelosi to try and
unseat her in her district
um republican i know a democrat a
progressive though like uh
in line with the prime minister aoc
passed already yeah no it did and
and that's the thing and i think that
like fundamentally the democratic party
is ready to move on to a different set
of ideas a more true fulfillment maybe
of what it could mean for its citizens
and the party by the by the citizenry
the actual elected officials though have
every trick in the book that they can
pull out to maintain themselves
in power for as long as is humanly
possible and this is my argument for why
trump needs to win
oh no joe biden is a 47-year
establishment crony who wants
control of the executive branch to seal
the doors and never allow any challenge
ever again
they are upset that they lost in 2016
they weren't supposed to
they did everything to crush bernie
sanders and donald trump is the
insurgent who upended the republican
party and they hated his guts too
now they're beholden to him here's
here's my opinion
and you and and i asked for yours and
afterward if joe biden gets in
he's locking the doors they're going to
shore up the fences they're going to
install their bureaucrats they're going
to make sure that you guys don't get a
foot in the door
ever you got too close with bernie
sanders trump
see here's the thing bernie sanders
left-wing populist
donald trump right-wing populist the
elites did not like either of them
the establishment republicans hate trump
and that's that's exemplified by the
lincoln project and the cronies who have
now
are now just espousing whatever the
democrats want him to say if joe biden
wins
they get back in the ivory tower they
bolt the doors shut and they laugh at
both populist wings
trump was a bull brought to the gates
who stormed in trashed everything and
the democrats are freaking out but still
in there
bernie sanders was very polite hello
hello let me in please i'll i'll agree
with you i'll stop saying the
millionaires
if joe biden wins i believe there will
never be
another populist be it left right or
whatever i think if trump wins
joe biden was the best they could muster
they are done
if joe biden gets in and kamala harris
then ends up being that person in charge
there will never be a bernie sanders
there will never be a leftist populist
but if trump gets in and the
establishment withers and dies over the
next four years because trump's going
nuts he's going to fire everybody
he's stripping all these government
protections from these employees he said
he's going to fire that of the cia put
his own cronies in yeah
i don't i don't but he's going to be
able to do that and if he fires them
somebody has to go there but that's but
that's still an argument beyond what
he's is doing so
so maybe that's an issue but if donald
trump gets rid of the bureaucrats and he
strips the establishment of its power
then i believe in 2024 you're going to
see something new and wild whatever it
is i don't think it's going to be trump
12 years i think joe biden is the best
they could muster up to try and save the
crony establishment
and the republicans like rick wilson and
the other lincoln project people
joined forces with them showing us who
they really are
joe biden is getting more money from
wall street than trump is he gets more
money from the wealthy than trump does
he is the he is the establishment
billionaire candidate who is being
protected by
big tech and billionaires who are
censoring stories that might hurt him
okay let biden go okay so we've got a
lot to unpack here oh yeah
first of all um i fail to see in any
meaningful way how trump is
anti-establishment
he has consolidated an enormous amount
of power into the federal government he
seems as if not more comfortable with
executive orders than obama ever did
he's up drone strikes
and what's more he has fundamentally
eroded the institutions which are meant
to challenge the government
the media is the media bad absolutely
but the media still serves a very useful
role in this country as ineffectually as
they do
the media has constantly called the i'm
sorry trump has constantly called the
media the enemy of the people he's
threatened to remove press badges from
people who are mean to him at press
conferences i know obama did that to fox
news
obama not it's the degree to which this
took place is not even comparable these
are two different
worlds and calling press the enemy of
the people is like fascism 101.
i don't care about right-leaning people
getting their populists in office
right-leaning populism has a name it's
fascism i don't want these people
it no it unquestionably is i don't want
these people in office i don't care
about you define fascism yeah fascism is
an ultra uh
ultra-nationalist far-right form of
governments which relies on the assembly
of the common will
uh the unification of a um of a national
narrative against enemies from both
within from without
it usually has to focus on things like
mcchismo or perhaps on the belief in a
type of ethnic or racial supremacy so
how would you define right-wing
libertarians
right i don't think there is a such
thing as a right-wing libertarian well
how is that how is that possible
because i have never met one i keep
talking to people who say they are and
then they stop being libertarian the
moment it comes to literally any issue
other than taxes and weed there was a
dude who took his clothes off on the
stage
of the libertarian debate to argue about
freedom and they had a debate over
whether or not kids should
you should be allowed to sell heroin to
kids yeah oh well there they are some
amazing people
um i will not deny it but they aren't
they aren't populist libertarian
wait but i have to say because we we
have we have so much to unpack here
with regards to trump okay uh is joe
biden a candidate that i feel proud of
voting for of course not absolutely
they're not even gonna waste time
defending that when it comes to the
means for
populism to interfere with the
government
after joe biden wins i am optimistic
uh he has managed to that is to say uh
bernie sanders has extracted an enormous
number of concessions from joe biden
and what's more there are incl
increasing signs that the popularity of
the
of the squad and other um more populist
left-leaning progressive sometimes even
socialist candidates they are starting
to wean in on the democratic party
the constant conflict between pelosi and
aoc
and the fact that at certain points
pelosi has had to defer public opinion
to aoc in those respects as an
indication that
within that party there is a real chance
at these
dinosaurs i think the average age of the
democratic politician is like 71 or
something
these dinosaurs being ousted now mind
you i am a socialist i don't think aoc
is radical enough
but i recognize that progressive change
in a given direction is preferable
especially when we recognize what we're
gambling with here
even if i were to believe that donald
trump was some sort of
anti-establishment bull
and i don't consolidated heavy amounts
of federal power
defunded institutions what does that
mean well the um the uh constant use of
executive action
uh the fact that he has normalized
attacks on institutions which
attack him like for example his attempt
to try and get the fbi director fired
during the russia gate investigation
or the constant attacks on the press and
the media or the fact
that he seems to be contemptuous of the
very idea of losing an election itself
wait
so uh he's consolidating federal power
but trying to also fire the heads of
these organizations
it's fair i'm sorry i should be more
specific executive power
the right but hasn't he been heavily
constrained
in every direction he's been sued a
million times yeah because he keeps
breaking the law he breaks the law
constantly like no he he does yeah he
has uh
engaged in scandal after scandal after
scandal over the course of his
presidency
with what i mean name law is broken
um because we hear it a lot i can tell
you that uh
does trump use his authority and push
really hard and then get challenged in
the courts and lose sometimes and win
sometimes
yes sure so we can talk about the
administration first of all the
rustigrate
the russiagate investigation led to
literally dozens of credible indictments
and arrests
uh with regards to their
misappropriation of funds or with their
collaboration with foreign governments
we have the ukraine scandal of course
with regards to him
bartering aid with their willingness to
help him it seems true now though
what do you mean that joe biden was was
using his son as an intermediary you
still can't withhold aid
on the condition that they released that
well so it's an argument about whether
or not trump had a right to withhold age
he did that's illegal
wait i'm not wait i've i have never at
any point in my life defended joe biden
no no
i know i know but if we can make that
argument we could say then joe biden's
doing the same thing
yeah the difference is that joe biden
wasn't the president of the united
states
yeah i mean if you want you can you're
free to investigate you're free to
investigate when you do this
what do you mean like the why why is
like the media in the space basically
the media wait you this this
organization this vague conspiracy
you guys are the media too no no no the
new york times and the wall street
journal have both now written that there
was a big effort to
not cover the biden scandal i would need
to look into the specifics of it
one of the things that i don't like when
we talk about like the relative the
badness of these characteristics is when
we start playing defense for them
on the assumption that the media is
going after them or not going after them
the left-leaning media will go after
left-leaning aims right-leaning media
will go after right-leaning aims
there is no such thing as journalistic
integrity or objectivity there are only
people in power and money
well the establishment media i don't
know what the establishment is new york
times for instance
how is that just the what what about fox
news is the most viewed
uh news station in the country tucker
carlson is the largest pundit
talk show uh chris cuomo and rachel
maddow got combined
i mean eight million and you know what
you know tucker carlson got
in his average was five so if you're
coming he's peaked at tens of millions
hasn't he
didn't what hasn't he peaked recently he
got like his ratings hit like
five five million was like the
historical record he's like the most
viewed my goodness
but when you combine cnn msnbc abc nbc
cbs
it's tenfold because you're because
you're combining all of the left-wing
media
and arguably some of these are barely
left-leaning with very part
with one partisan right media if you
take a look at
all of talk radio if you take a look at
um uh uh
fox news if you take a look at uh take a
look at oan for example
oh no it's not it's not great but it
does have a lot of influence within the
government because we know that trump
watches it and trump is himself a form
of media
when he talks about things the
broadcasts that he give he reflects
essentially far-right partisan talking
points
these are in many ways reflective of the
political opinions that right-leaning
people have forthcoming
we we we got off a little bit here i
want i want to talk specifically though
about uh trump with regards to his
practice in government
even if we're to leave aside the
supported criminality of any
candidate because as far as i'm
concerned being the president is a crime
i'm not uh i'm not
it's a weird job i'm really not in a
position to okay with the president but
i'd like to have more this is one of the
things that i've said uh even if
cause you know you don't want bernie
sanders to win you would you my
fellow lefties whoever's watching would
be devastated to see what even a
left-leaning person has to do to be
and stay president in the united states
uh
especially with regards to foreign
policy but if we want to look past that
stuff if we want to look at stuff like
climate change or if we want to look at
stuff regarding like education
or if we want to look at stuff just
regarding like the fundamental
gentleman's agreements that have
operated in this country for
centuries now that seem to be unweaving
i don't think that the trump presidency
is anti-establishment i think that he's
very pro-corporate i think he's very
pro-government as long as it's
his government i think that his
persistent refusal
to acknowledge uh that if he loses
in the election that he should actually
step down peacefully is terrifying
and i think that while joe biden is a
haughty institutionalist
crony who probably has as many original
thoughts in he
in his head that weren't given to him by
like focus groups as like a
your average chipmunk yeah i think that
he is
a a that's that's me to chill yeah i i
apologize
i'm sure i've known many wonderful
chipmunks um i i think that he is
at least with regards to climate change
which i think is a very simple
very very easy thing to focus on an
objective
uh improvement and that he also allows
for meaningful left-wing populism as
opposed to
what trump is which is a gateway to
very very bad far-right populism have
you read about obamacare
uh yes i have uh you mean the thing
where he spied on trump
so well like the meeting with sally
yates and comey and biden
and and obama where uh uh where joe
biden suggested using the logan act
against michael flynn to falsely uh
prosecute him where they then threatened
his son with imprisonment
unless he agreed to testify against
trump
okay did any of that actually happen
yeah yeah yeah okay so
so to clarify though uh the the notes
that were released in the investigation
by the fbi show that there was a note
scrawled
that uh ascribed logan act
to joe biden in a meeting with sally
yates immediately afterwards i think it
was sally yates who then wrote an email
to herself explaining everything
happened and sent it to her
and then several government employees in
the fbi took out liability insurance
saying in like i'm paraphrasing that
we're in serious trouble we better buy
insurance because we're going to get
sued over this
i can't speak to the specifics of this i
know that trump has vaguely alluded to
some sort of
left conspiracy to deny him the
presidency which has always come off
very um
fascist to me the notes are released uh
do you know about the peter stroke and
lisa page things
i ca i i have to say and i apologize if
this comes off like uh
um i guess disinterested but uh having
followed i guess the events leading up
to and i've explored this obamacare
thing pretty extensively from what i've
seen and from the media sources that
i've looked at and the information the
analysis
i haven't seen anything that even
remotely justifies the claims that trump
has made about this do you know about
the text messages between lisa page and
peter strzok i don't know the
specificity so where he said we're going
to stop him we have an insurance policy
like this is this is all public
information i think the issue is when
you talk about russiagate and trump's
actions
it's coming from a place of you not
actually looking at the evidence no i i
i assure you i have the issue is that
you didn't know about the meeting with
comey and yates no i'm i'm the logan act
and what michael flynn was threatened
with
and like do you know about the ongoing
court case where judge sullivan is
blocking
the prosecutor like the government from
dropping its own case no i'm familiar
with the things that you referred to
here
the issue is that what usually happens
with this is that there are a lot of
nuances to these cases that need to be
looked over thoroughly and usually the
way they're presented is extremely
hyperbolic like russiagate
well russiagate prov again keep in mind
this is the big difference between
right leaning in the claims in
russiagate russiagate was investigated
dozens of indictments and arrests all
these accusations
they well they were brought about by the
investigation into russiagate involving
the misappropriation of campaigns
a lawyer who was recently indicted on
altering evidence to frame carter page
and get false fisa warrants to
investigate in the russia gate
so some of these may have been maybe
what what's it saying uh
fruit of the poison tree fruit of the
poison tree or the poison tree yeah i
mean a lot of the trump administration
has found themselves arrested you know
how paul manafort ended up getting
uh found out it was actually ukrainians
colluding with the dnc operative and
providing documents which
which led to the investigation of
manafort so it was all
overtly political actions there's
nothing well
there's nothing necessarily wrong with
political actions we're talking about
the investigation of a political
of a political administration of the
trump administration the reason i bring
this up is
what and by the way we've moved somewhat
off of the electability or the
electoralism
so here's the point the the way you
framed everything about trump and the
actions and the things he was
saying firing comey sounds like comey
should have been fired based on the
information that's come out since he
fired him that is
wait hold on that is apps first of all
even if that is the case which i
sincerely doubt it is that is absolutely
not why trump claimed to the evidence
that was provided with regards to his
attempt
was he wanted comey fired because comey
was looking into him you can't post talk
justify
an illegal act because it turns out
later trump tweeted
early way on way early that he was being
spied on by obama
he wasn't being spied on by obama so so
the accusations
that i had had informants that were
going and having meetings with trump's
people and then
spying on them that is what the fbi does
so sure so
you have people who were spying on
trump's campaign it's a colloquial i
mean if you want to argue semantics
about no that's the fbi does that for
every campaign that's their job
so if you have before trump has
inaugurated a meeting with obama yates
comey
and then you have these notes you have
these text messages between fbi agents
and trump knew about this but it wasn't
declassified so trump took action and
fired the guy i mean it sounds justified
well he didn't fight he attempted to
fire the guy and he wasn't able to
call me yeah well no the comey was like
i have a great recollection trump said
this to me and i'm like
no no the um uh when he was being
investigated for the russia stuff oh my
goodness
throw those cats i think a cat just
knocked me up no i did
oh okay well the cat ran afterwards oh
we got to fix everything
anyway you keep talking yes no his his
efforts
to uh to fire there was um the
intermediary who asked to fire the guy
i'm forgetting his name right now
um the um uh the person who he attempted
to uh fire and he said no
and then trump fired that guy mm-hmm um
do you remember that was that uh that
was his name i can't remember him yeah
i'm completely honest
resigned no i know yes sessions right
look i'm not bringing this up to be like
everything
yeah i just feel like well no no but
it's just it's it's interesting to me
because again it's just it falls
like on this big conspiracism like with
regard it's not it's not vague i mean
look if you read the news on these
things you know what i'm talking about
no i bet i have it's just
a lot of these claims get jumbled up and
to be honest i forget which narrative
which universe that i'm operating at any
given point
with regards to like the uh russiagate
investigation there was solid evidence
they went in they investigated what was
the evidence the evidence with regards
to the rust
russiagate investigation um wasn't there
like um
uh some evidence that there may have
been like meetings with held with
members of the trump administration uh
with regards to them accepting uh deals
or information from
are you sure i mean it's been like three
years since this was politically
relevant
what i can tell you is that we know that
the fisa warrants
were obtained through uh malpractice i
guess that you can put it
so we had uh so they lied uh a next fbi
lawyer has been indicted and charged for
altering evidence to imply that carter
page
was not an uh was not um an asset of the
cia
when he was having these meetings when
in fact he was doing it for the us
government
yeah i'd have to look at it so so they
they essentially got bunk fisa warrants
then we ended up with before trump got
it got inaugurated you have these notes
released that
to the best of our understanding it's
it's a meeting between several
individuals in the obama administration
to try and find a way to go after
michael flynn to
get him to i guess the fbi
notes actually read what's our goal i
think it's a text message what's our
goal
to prosecute or get him fired my
question when that came out was
why why is the fbi trying to get a guy
fired from his job where were they
obama told trump not to hire michael
flynn
trump hired him anyway i guess trump did
it as an f.u to obama
so for some reason then obama has a
meeting
they take notes on logan act maybe for
michael flynn then michael flank is
accused of breaking the logan act
or or this is this is what launched the
investigation even though no one's ever
been prosecuted under the logan act it's
an obscure law that says
u.s individuals can't represent
themselves as agents of a government
because as acting national security
adviser he had a conversation
with the russian ambassador asking him
not to escalate uh tensions between the
countries
that was the justification for launching
this this
it was it was insane then you have text
messages between peter struck and lisa
page
where they're saying we have an
insurance policy we'll stop him
so trump complains about this trump
wants to fire these people
but then the russian gate investigate
investigation stopped him from taking
any action against them
i'll tell you what man if at the end of
this we say no trump no biden but we get
rid of all of these intelligence
bureaucrats i'm down
i'm totally down you'll find most
leftists aren't big fans of intelligence
agencies
for sure for sure so when trump says
that
like i'll put it this way do you agree
with trump then when he says that um
they're spying on me they didn't i don't
didn't even get my first term frankly i
should be allowed
a third term no okay but i'll tell you
this
because he says a lot of really weird
stuff somehow now i could no i'm at
something of a disadvantage here and i
apologize for that because with regards
to the russiagate investigation thing
it's been a while since i've brushed up
on this
respective information i do know that
the investigation that did lead to
a number of legitimate um investigations
and um arrests and indictments and i
think there's something to be said about
that
i feel it's often very difficult to
understand the totality of like a
government conspiracy or like something
going on behind the scenes
until everything is sussed out through a
proper investigation and for that reason
sometimes it can be really difficult to
understand
not only the specificity of events that
have taken place but the severity of
them as well
because if you if you want to and i'm
not saying you're doing this because
everyone does this to some extent
if you want to a disparate set of pieces
of information
that can be uh assessed and collected
and presented in such a way as to
given narrative and then once you have
that narrative you can run with it and
that's what trump has done very often
with this obama gate thing for example
like i remember when a reporter asked
him what obama gate was and he was like
you know and then he walked away which i
think was fair i think it was trump
not knowing well well then i mean that's
the thing and that's one of the issues
that i have as well
the the i think that there has probably
been more confused information put out
from our government over the past four
years
um than possibly any other single
presidential administration
in large part because there doesn't seem
to be any sort of cohesive narrative
it's just scraps of information being
used whenever they're politically
convenient and discarded when they're
not
and this is if i may bring this back
around to what we were talking about
earlier
one of the things that really concerns
me about trump this is an
anti-establishment tendency
this is just incompetent governance this
doesn't break the government in a way
that makes it more fair or more
representative or more kind more decent
or more efficient
this is a type of governance which just
makes it worse so do you want a
competent establishment or an
incompetent one
i mean competent in certain ways when it
comes to coronavirus handling
when it comes to the um dissemination of
healthcare when it comes to proper
schooling
all areas i think trump has been
woefully inadequate in i would
absolutely prefer a competent
establishment
because education handled properly
empowers us
not keeping us in our homes to be sick
and die from coronavirus that empowers
us
there are ways the government when
managed properly even in an
establishment sense even like
even like someone like obama who i hate
obama
um can give us tools that we need to
become stronger
the best example of this that i use and
i use this when arguing with bernier
busters all the time
is um they say obama stopped the wheels
of history his
his corporate neo-liberalism prevented
the american people from waking up and
recognizing what was wrong with the
system
and i say to them okay i don't like
obama either great sure
after obama had two terms guess who
ended up coming in second narrow second
under hillary clinton the next
democratic primaries
some nobody independent senator
who then in large part because people
were disillusioned with obama but
nonetheless given the tools
to think and to act that's the internet
the internet yeah but also people
weren't terrified of a pandemic or of
global warming at least not as much as
they are today uh people weren't um
dealing with substandard schooling the
more people are terrified and confined
and weakened by their circumstances
the less politically emancipated they
are you know what makes it a real
challenge having conversations like this
is just that there's a lot of things
you've read that i have a lot of things
i've read you haven't
and there are a lot of people who have
read things that neither of us have or
haven't
but everybody expects us to like come to
a definitive understanding
and solution within the span of a couple
hours i'm just bringing it up because i
know that no one's going to be satisfied
oh i have never come to a definitive
solution on anything of
any length of time in the conversation
the reason i say this is because
uh when you bring up global warming when
you bring up the far right
when you bring up russiagate i'm like
wow to like have a conversation on each
of those subjects would take an
hour to three or four hours like so
just to briefly mention this in your
opinion you said
there's no actual right-wing
libertarians because whenever it comes
to it they actually end up
you know being more authoritative
libertarianism was originally a leftist
ideology
and it was appropriated yeah i i don't
want to get into it just i'm just
yeah yeah yeah mentioned that then
there's also like russiagate where
you're like
oh it's been a while since i talked to
us and then i like the reason i brought
that up was like oh we got to really
break that down to address
one point and then climate change
there's a lot there too like
what are we doing internationally what
would joe like why hasn't joe biden done
anything about china not not to open up
those conversations i'm just pointing
out
there's a lot in each of those we'd have
to actually break down yeah
it's literally impossible too even if
you have a very specific policy focused
discussion on one issue
say school choice that's a big one for
republicans these days that's
easily a three-hour discussion depending
on how many sources you bring that can
go the whole day
are you super school choice i am not for
school choice now why not why not
why should people have the right to just
choose i think it puts the blame in that
so here's my concern right
individual responsibility is the mantra
of the republican party
why are things in your life not going
well individual responsibility
often sometimes that's true we are
agents capable of making our own
decisions
but when it comes to systemic issues
like neighborhoods with poor schooling
these people don't get bad educations
because of poor decision making they get
it because their neighborhoods have been
wastelands that the government hasn't
invested in for decades
my concern and this is what i fear i
wake up at night in the sweat thinking
about this
it's imagine some single black lady you
know
two kids two jobs and now all of a
sudden
school choice happens her local district
is crap
there's one 30 minutes away she could
drive her kids to maybe even 20 minutes
away
that's better okay so you drive your
kids to and from well
maybe you don't have time for that do
you hire like a sitter to do it no you
send them to the crappy school
they would normally have to go to right
but that's the thing and now
when that woman writes online
or writes an article or appears at a
town hall
and she says what can i do i am
struggling the answer is
you should have took them to a better
school sure that worries me well why
take away the option
because i think there's a better
solution to the same problem
we just invest in these communities also
we have to keep in mind if a lot of
people choose to move to different
school districts or like take their kids
there whatever you know
the school district that's already there
is going to be even worse
because these schools get funding based
on you know participation
uh they're going to get cut more and
more meaning it'll be even worse
for the people who don't have the option
to go to the other ones i say
why give people why enable
people to leave their wasteland and
blame them if they don't when we could
just fix the wasteland so so this gets
into the bigger question
about socialism i suppose why i'm not a
fan of socialism i'm in favor of a mixed
economy i'll get you one day
mixed economy i think we need regulation
but i think we need people to
freely trade and the issue i take with
schools for instance is that when they
have problems we just dump more money
into it
as if a general investment fixes it the
problem though is
we say okay what about review boards
what if we have like a review of the
expenditures
nobody wants to be the person to to cut
the job or to
to gut the schools and then when people
actually do they complain the schools
are being gutted
if the school isn't functioning properly
and i shouldn't say school
just government spending in general what
we tend to see like in chicago for
example
for instance is you get a wound this is
the way to describe it you get a wound
in your in your society where you have
people who are suffering or struggling
we put a band-aid on it we say we're
gonna we're gonna provide funding in
this area try and solve the problem
a few years ago buying this house going
i don't know throw more money into it
and they put another band at the top of
a band yep
eventually you have a festering wound
it's never been solved a lot of mandates
because you a lot of it because they
keep trying this i don't disagree by the
way throwing money at schools doesn't
work i think we've seen this time and
time and time
right well there are some like for
example like uh like the more you give
like the epa money they can
like more reliable um testing or
whatever but um
generally speaking yeah i think like
schools in particular and the reason for
that is because schools aren't a product
of the money that goes into them
schools are a product of the minds that
are inside of them from administration
to teachers to the students
the issue is minds born under broken
circumstances
are just more fragile that's just how it
is money on its own is not the solution
what i'd like to see the pipe dreaming
here is a proper public works program
instituted in certain districts in this
country a lot of the big the issue that
we have here
is that um the reason these kids don't
care about school is because they know
nothing's going to come from it a lot of
the people in their neighborhoods end up
burnt out druggies anyway with
absolutely nothing to do with their
lives
because there's just no opportunity
public works programs you have to invest
in the community not by paying private
contractors to do it but by paying the
inhabitants of that community
fair healthy salaries you need to have
works up there you can have for example
revitalization of the rails and the
roads and the public transportation
people become less reliant on cars i
mean they have to pay less car payments
there are so many things that you can do
to these neighborhoods and this is
class-based i don't want this to be like
a black or a white thing
there are white communities in this
country that are struggling and i think
that
if with these steps we can we can i
don't know man just the idea of an
america where it's like
here's a quarter of the country we just
don't go there you can invest in new
kinds of roads made out of bitumen which
will last for like decades but
they like planned obsolescence they want
to build things that will break
so that they can spend more money on it
again yeah and that's where the money's
coming
want to be under budget and they want to
be friends of the corporation
so so i mean look there's a lot of
problems i want to say can i say one
thing quickly about socialism i don't
mean to interrupt i apologize
um it's great it's been it's yeah so let
me just talk about that for five
what i'm in favor of is something called
a worker's state um this is called by
some people a dictatorship of the
proletariat which is a horrible term
because it was termed before the term
dictatorship meant what it currently
means
but it essentially means i just want a
state where the workers have power
that doesn't mean bring out the
guillotines or anything it just means
that when i think of like um
what is a good country like what is a
good democracy or a good republic look
like to me
i imagine one where the people inside of
it
have a lot of control over what goes on
in a way that's responsibly channeled
it's not just like crazy
you know will of the masses stuff and
one of the big issues to me is that
as you just pointed out corporations
have a lot of power in this country
and we defer to them quite a bit of
government power as well
much in the way that the old monarchies
did with with mercantilism you know
you want to do an east india trading
company spice run you know
you get the kingsguard to help you you
get that fleet because the state is
invested in the corporation succeeding
the corporation makes a lot of money off
that mutual partnership
but if these corporations or these
construction companies or
even these schools frankly are being run
by people from the community
who have a lot of internal democratic
control within it i think that could go
a long way towards fixing this problem
we see
where we just put money into these
problems and it just burns through it
falls through
i i i think one of the problems we have
with with all government spending
is that we don't know how they've how to
fail them whereas with
businesses they mostly just fail the big
problem i see with with the way things
going right now
for one i think a lot of the critiques
of capitalism are more about the massive
corporate structure
and the imbalance of power that once you
research reach a certain threshold of
of capital or wealth you just own the
system you will never be poor you will
never fail again
your kids will never fail i mean that's
not necessarily true there's
generational wealth fades
right right small businesses fail all
the time but if you're an
ultra wealthy person you keep pumping
money in until you figure it out
so or lobby to get subsidies or
tax breaks and then you just forever so
these are these these are the two issues
i i see and it's interesting because
this argument is actually more of a
classical
i guess a left and right argument of the
days of yesteryear
10 years ago when it was like government
versus corporations i remember
you know during like occupy you had a
lot of people on the left saying the
government can help us we need these
programs
and the right was like we need the free
market we need the corporate solutions
and i'm like
both are problems in different ways
massive multinational corporations
you're both wrong right
you're both just so awful government and
massive corporations
we want small government small business
so
i i like a mixed economy i think we need
to figure out how we do government
programs in a way that
if they fail they fail and we need to
make sure we don't have massive
multinational corporations with no
interest in helping the people but
selling them out because they can get
better laws
to violate human rights in in other
countries where they can just hire
people for a quarter
and then have them do you know
essentially slave labor and then sell
garbage to the american people at a
marked up price
and then become thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you